now another fun love story is you and
kaylee cuoco what is going on there you
guys are roomies you're co-starring
together
what how this is the cutest story you
guys got tattoo tell me about that
i mean we always say that our love
started with a boop i'm actually saved
as boop in her phone
so the first time we ever met which very
few people believe was our chemistry
read for this show and um they're like
feel free to improv and i was like
okay great
um and okay to this day i'm like katie
why did you do that she's like i don't
know i just had an urge and she walked
up
and i turned around and she booped me on
the nose
she literally went boop and i went oh i
hate it when you do that don't do that
and i like smacked her hand away
and
we're i wouldn't know we just have said
something we're like that's the moment
that our friendship was born it's just
like it was like when you fall in love
and we fell in love and now poor evan
has to deal with um
me being in love with another we
literally i
one of her rap gifts cause we go to
iceland in season two i made her um a
sweatshirt that says wife in icelandic
i love it it's a little it's a little
crazy so this was um she actually
surprised me
um we got a tattoo with our costume
department after season one and we walk
in and her cousin's best friend is this
amazing tattoo artist and she had
scheduled for us to get those tattoos i
think you're a lover but it seems like
everybody loves you really hard back
which is so amazing and i'm so happy
what is a life lived without putting it
all out there and laughing as hard as
you can and loving is big i know it
sounds like a bad mug you know live
laugh dance i don't know whatever but
it's like it's true it is true i mean i
think it's why it's on a mug i mean it's
like it is why it's on a mop it's on a
mug
[Music]
you